today the Matt wall show heading into
election day Democrats have grown
desperate in their attempts to deflect
on the crime issue also a big update on
our efforts to ban gender transitions of
minors in the state of Tennessee Trump
launches an attack on Ron DeSantis two
days before the election Elon Musk
continues to unveil his vision for
Twitter going forward and I have some
questions and SNL starts making the kova
jokes they should have been making two
years ago all of that and more today on
the Matt Walsh show
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
you know I'm not a gym person I'm a dad
of four soon to be six I don't spend
hours at the gym after work I go home to
my wife and my kids I like Echelon
Fitness because it brings the gym home
to me Echelon Fitness is the affordable
way to get workout equipment a workout
community and an instructor's motivation
right in the comfort and privacy of your
own home Echelon Fitness is connected
app provides thousands of Live And
on-demand classes with great music to
keep you moving you can work out anytime
day or night their full range of
affordable workout equipment includes
stationary bikes smart rower Sleek
Fitness screens and an auto folding
treadmill these are all connected to the
echelon fitness app for The Full
Experience Around the Clock uh classes
including full body workout programs
will keep you coming back one membership
covers a family of five and for a
limited time my audience can get a free
bike or rowing machine with a 24 month
membership to get your free bike a rower
text Matt to 818181 that's Matt to
818181 to claim your free bike or rowing
machine text Matt to 81818 one message
and data rates may apply C terms for
details
well I'm not sure if you can really call
it election day considering that the
votes will be neither cast nor counted
in their entirety tomorrow but whatever
we call it the point is that
theoretically the voters will make their
choice and theoretically we will find
out what that choice is and if the red
wave materializes as many have
forecasted it will no doubt have a lot
to do with the flagging economy and Sky
High inflation at least we think there
is Sky High inflation as Joy Reid points
out we're all just a bunch of dumb Hicks
though and inflation is the first
multi-syllabic word we've ever learned
so who knows
the only people I ever heard here use
the word inflation are journalists
um and economists right so that is not
part of the normal lexicon of the way
people talk so it's interesting that
Republicans are doing something they
don't normally do right which is not
used com the common tongue right not
used as common English to sort of use do
on their campaigns like they're doing
with prime but what they've done is
they've taught people the word inflation
right most people who would have never
used that word ever in their lives are
using it now because they've been taught
it including on TV including in
newspapers they've been taught this word
and they they sort of wrap this word
around whatever it is that they really
want to vote you know the reasons they
really want to vote
yes who bought an economist has ever
used the word inflation when discussing
the economy for that matter who's ever
used the word economy or money or
financial you know I don't know what any
of these words mean personally prior to
all this Republican propagandizing I
communicated my opinion on financial
matters through a series of Grunts and
frantic hand gestures but if that
argument from Joy Reed seems utterly
desperate and absurd it is still
downright credible compared to the last
ditch Democrat efforts to change the
narrative on crime now perhaps even
before the economy or at least very
closely behind it the crime problem will
be a leading Factor driving voter
turnout on Tuesday it's too late for
Democrats to do anything about crime
itself they have no interest in doing
anything about it anyway nor would they
know what to do even if they wanted to
do something about it instead at the
11th Hour
they're looking for a way to reframe the
conversation
briefly last week it seemed that they
would go into the election with the
counter-intuitive narrative that in fact
it is Republicans who are weak on crime
not Democrats this claim was made by
many people on the left but typified by
Gavin Newsom on NBC last week let's
listen to that
but we have a messaging problem I really
believe it and you can argue what are we
doing on comprehensive immigration
reform what are we doing in a number of
other issues I'm not going to deny the
substantive challenges our party has as
well addressing those tough and vaccine
issues it's not just a messaging problem
but a messaging problem that has
persisted with our party for years and
years constantly on the defense we allow
these culture wars to take shape and we
consist in there on the back end of them
eight of the top 10 states with the
highest murder rates all are Republican
states
how do Democrats not know that in fact
it's really nine out of 10 Georgia went
for Biden but it's really a Republican
state at least a red State eight out of
ten and we're losing that message
crime is higher as well as taxes here
for the average uh citizen in Texas it's
higher crime higher violent crime and
poverty crimes than in the state of
California 67 percent higher gun death
rate in Texas why don't we push back why
aren't we why why don't we I don't know
you know speaking of terms nobody ever
used before now I've heard people say
inflation
but there's a reason why until just now
nobody ever talked about a state's
murder rate
you know no one ever said don't go to
Indiana that state has a high murder
rate that's because the murder or
violent crime rate of an entire state
is a useless statistic what matters are
the crime statistics in individual
cities and localities so a person who
lives on five acres of land in the
wealthy rural town of Bel Air Maryland
does not in any meaningful sense share a
murder rate with somebody living an hour
away in West Baltimore
Maryland is not an unsafe state
but Baltimore is an unsafe city city
neither is Texas you know there are no
states that are in their entirety unsafe
but cities can be unsafe
cities can be crime ridden murder plague
drug infested wastelands
and it just so happens that nearly all
of those cities are run by democrats in
fact out of the 30 cities with the
highest murder rates all but three are
run by the Democrat Party
so if a red state has a crime problem
it's only because of the blue cities
within those States Missouri is a
perfect example there are plenty of nice
areas in Missouri well some anyway you
know I've been hiking in some parts of
the some some of the state parks there
as a state though it also has one of the
highest murder rates in the country but
that is driven almost entirely by St
Louis and Kansas City which are both run
by democrats
you'll find the same pattern in every
red state my state of Tennessee has a
spike in crime rate thanks largely to
the efforts of Memphis which is run by
Democrat Birmingham is having a similar
effect on the state of Alabama and the
list goes on
there is no red State Crime problem
there is a blue City crime problem as
even the most cursory glance at the data
shows
and that might be why the left has
shifted gears in the closing days of the
campaign season from acknowledging the
crime wave but blaming it on Republicans
to once again denying that it's
happening at all
this is all the fault of Republicans
also it's not happening they argue which
is a radical departure from their usual
argument which is this isn't happening
and also it's the fault of Republicans
so over on NBC Lester Holt blamed the
fear the fear over crime on videos and
startling headlines but warns that quote
crime isn't always what it appears to be
as candidates fine-tune their closing
messages ahead of Tuesday's vote and
issue Finding Traction for many
campaigns is voter worries about crime
but as we found the state of crime in
America is not always what it appears to
be
is on the ballot crime now the center
piece of campaigns across the country
vote like your life depends on it
because it does fueled some argue not by
reality but by videos of rampant
lawlessness They smash glass display
cases filled their bags of jewelry then
took off and some unsettling headlines
unsettling headlines perhaps this is
what Kathy holciel and uh New York meant
last week when she said that violent
crime epidemic it's a conspiracy theory
and just in time Pew Research Center put
out a report claiming that in fact
violent crime rates are falling the
report's been championed by many
journalists including faux journalist
hack
Judd Lagoon who tweeted a screenshot of
one chart from the report with the
caption America's violent crime wave is
a hoax over the last 30 years violent
crime is down dramatically and there's
no recent increase
don't believe you're lying eyes Judd
says there is no crime wave indeed if
you are currently being beaten over the
head by a meth crazed homeless man on
the subway
take solace in the knowledge that what
is happening to you is a hoax
a conspiracy theory
there's a reason why Judd didn't
actually provide a link to the report
itself
because if he had he would have uh he
would have he would find that the single
paragraph
that seemingly supports the hoax claim
and this is what it says there's one
paragraph and it says for each of the
four violent crime types tracked in the
survey
simple assault aggravated assault
robbery and rape sexual assault there
was no statistically significant
increase either in 2020 or 2021
that's that's it right there
but you know there are a lot more
paragraphs in the report so you read a
few more paragraphs down and you find
this the most recent version of the FBI
study shows no rise in the national
violent crime rate between 2020 and
2021. that said there is considerable
uncertainty around the FBI's figures for
2021 because of a transition to a new
data collection system the FBI reported
an increase in violent crime rate
between 2019 and 2020 when the previous
data collection system was still in
place
ah so there you have it violent crime
was increasing until the FBI changed its
data collection system at which point it
magically fell
how did that happen
well because nearly 40 percent of the
nation's law enforcement agencies didn't
submit their crime data in 2021 at all
that includes the NYPD the LAPD
so New York City in Los Angeles were
erased from the national violent crime
statistics along with hundreds of other
cities and what do you know just like
that the national violent crime rate
goes down so if you pretend that Los
Angeles and New York and a lot of other
cities with a lot of crime don't exist
then the crime rate goes down
you may have noticed another problem
though because the FBI's violent crime
statistics the ones that the media uses
to debunk the crime wave hoax quote
unquote
those stats don't include homicides
the worst form of violent crime the
thing that everyone principally has in
mind when they talk about violent crime
isn't factored in
that's what led to this unintentionally
hilarious tweet from journalist Mona
Charan over the bulwark She Wrote
other than murder violent crime is not
up did you know that violent crime is a
key midterm voting issue but what does
the data say
other than murder
that's like your doctor telling you well
other than the malignant tumor on your
brain you're you're in quite good health
God help any beachgoers if Mona is ever
the Lifeguard on duty yeah that guy over
there seems to be drowning but other
than that I think he's okay
or imagine Mona as the the investigator
interviewing the Lone Survivor of an
airplane crash so other than the whole
crash thing how was the flight
I mean the absurdity is is obvious you
can't make an exception for murder when
talking about violent crime any more
than you can make an exception for smoke
inhalation when talking about the
dangers of a house fire
and as for murder those rates are
dramatically up
Nationwide murders have increased 30
percent
and are the highest they've been in over
three decades
homicide rates have indeed risen
exponentially
at a rate rarely seen in American
history
so the crime wave is not a hoax it's not
a figment of your imagination
it is real
there's in fact all too real
so believe your own eyes and also your
common sense
and vote accordingly tomorrow
now let's get to our five headlines
you know I love spending the holidays
with my family and one of the ways that
I like to do that is with delicious meat
from good ranchers as a special gift to
my listeners this holiday season good
ranchers is giving away two Black Angus
New York strip steaks free with your
order there are two uh 12-ounce
Steakhouse quality cuts a 70 value for
free black angus tastes better and is
more tender than any other beef black
angus meat is marbled in such a way that
the fat is distributed thinly and evenly
this marbling gives you a consistent
flavor that you don't get with other
meats plus the Black Angus from good
ranchers is hand cut and trimmed by
expert butchers so you know every piece
is going to be Exquisite while grocery
store meat prices are on the rise good
ranchers is dedicated to helping you
save as much as possible if you
subscribe to good ranchers today you can
lock in your price and avoid those
insanely high prices at the grocery
store and get some free meat while
you're at it so it's the best of all
possible worlds go to goodranchors.com
Walsh use code walls to check out for
this special offer that's
goodranchors.com Walsh for two two Black
Angus New York strip steaks free with
your order
all right one thing I want to mention
just off the top here and there'll be a
lot more details about this in the
coming days but um I was just yesterday
shown a draft of the legislation in this
state that's going to ban quote gender
transition procedures for minors in
Tennessee so drugging and mutilating
children will be banned and also I can
tell you and again I can't get into all
the specifics but uh victims of these
procedures will be given the chance to
seek compensation which is a really
really important part of this
um and that's all gonna happen that
that's uh legislation will be introduced
on November 9th so the day right after
the election the legislation will be
will be uh officially submitted rather
and
and we're gonna we'll talk a lot more
about it when it's officially submitted
and we have the text of it but um we are
going to make this illegal in the state
so this is not just you know we had
we've had the rally we've raised
awareness we've talked a lot about it
um we've you know we've done all that
we've done the activism
the awareness raising all that's an
important part
but you got to follow that up with the
law you know you got to pass the laws
too and we're going to do that in this
state and uh and it's not going to stop
here as I've been saying all along this
is a national movement
you know you might recall a few months
ago
it was right when we got when we got
back to Tennessee after spending you
know a week in our undisclosed location
on rather a month on vacation I got back
here we have a new studio and I said
that we are going to start a nationwide
movement
to put an end to this the abuse of
children the indoctrination of children
into gender ideology we're going to put
a stop to it and
it has begun
so more to come on that
um as discussed Democrats are likely
headed for trouncing Stacy Abrams in
particular is in really bad shape she's
down by I think the last Paul I saw was
like eight points
which is terrible especially for an
incumbent given that she is currently
the governor of Georgia at least she she
thinks that she is and she still will be
after she loses obviously but the
Democrats are setting up the excuses now
for when she and she's their their star
right their uh their main attraction and
she's going to lose so Keisha Lance
bottoms is the failed former mayor of
Atlanta now Biden Lackey and she says
that misinformation is to blame for this
listen
mayor bottoms I picked up on that
because I'm just wondering her Stacey
Abrams focus on the misinformation
that's being targeted at black men and
it makes me wonder is she not getting
the black support she needs in her race
against Brian Kemp
listen Jonathan I I think that Stacy is
spot on with that I listen uh as my kids
watch NBA highlights and whatever else
they watch on YouTube I hear the
misinformation being typed in my 12 year
old my 14 year old son my 20 year old is
getting it so there is definitely a
Target toward an African-American men
oh yes uh well we all know all of that
right-wing propaganda during a
an NBA broadcast oh yeah it's like
infamously NBA broadcasts are a place
where they engage in all kind of uh
Republican you know all these Republican
talking points coming out of NBA
broadcast she says
so that's the narrative now
um and the narratives are just getting
more and more ridiculous as we go on so
the narrative now is that black men will
not vote for Stacy Abrams because the
right-wing propagandists during NBA
broadcasts have told them not to
that's the universe that the Democrats
want us all to Pretend We're living in
and Stacy Abrams has of course as a
reference there has echoed this herself
and uh you know that
you know your campaign's not doing well
when in you know three days four three
or four days before the election
you're you're publicly making excuses
ahead of time for why you're going to
lose
and that was our excuse let's listen
we have seen record turnout black men
have increased their participation rates
by 52 over 2018 and I do not believe
it's because of a deep well of
enthusiasm for my opponent we know that
black voters are often discounted and
unfortunately this year black men have
been a very targeted population for
misinformation not misinformation about
what they want but about why they want
what they deserve and my campaign has
been the only one that has very
intentionally thoughtfully and
consistently reached out that has been
misconstrued as concern when indeed it's
just respect
misinformation about why they want what
they deserve
what I don't even know how to interpret
that that's just nonsense
but if I were to attempt to to interpret
it
she's talking about misinformation so
like black men are misinterpreting their
own desires their own electoral wishes
um about about why they want what they
want they're misinterpreting that
because of misinformation
they think they don't want Stacy Abrams
but that's only because they're the
victims of misinformation she's saying
if you don't like me it's because you
because of misinformation could be the
only reason
meanwhile why is she really losing well
because first of all there's nothing
appealing about her whatsoever
she she is a creation
of the left-wing media
they selected her
and they selected her entirely on victim
points
this is an affirmative action case all
the way
she is not and I know that obviously I'm
biased because I'm not
on the left but but even so she has no
so I'm not I'm not factoring in politics
or ideology I would say disagree with
her on that
just looking from a from you know purely
from a purely marketing standpoint okay
she's not compelling she doesn't have
any charisma
I mean there are some politicians on the
left who I can't stand them or anything
they stand for but they do have some
political Talent she doesn't have any at
all
but based entirely on the victim points
she's a female she's black she's also
overweight that helps
I think there's an argument to be made
that if she was in better shape she
wouldn't be in this in the spot that
she's in they wouldn't have selected her
but that gives her another victim point
and so they've taken her and they've and
they've just said to the public she's a
star you all really like her and the
public keeps saying no we don't it's not
that we hate her it's just like we don't
there's nothing no it's she's just she
said nothing she's a nobody
she's totally unimpressive we're not
interested we're bored by her
who is this person
um
that's misinformation when they're
propaganda and their brainwashing
efforts don't work it that's
misinformation they say
and on top of that when it comes to what
she's actually sanctionable she has
nothing to say
of any substance whatsoever and she has
nothing to say to the voters
about how she's going to help them how
she's going to make their lives better
how she's going to make them safer more
prosperous
she has nothing to say about that and uh
that's why she's going to lose speaking
of insulting the voters I want to
there's a quick clip from uh that I
think I have from Joe Biden
um giving a speech
a couple days ago and here's how we
started things off listen to this
I love those signs when I came in
socialism
give me a break what it is socially
[Applause]
great angle on that angle is almost as
flattering as the you know ominous blood
red background that they infamously did
at the White House for his speech
yelling at the uh at the American people
and there we have him again
just you couldn't have thought you
couldn't you couldn't have come up with
a better
angry old man angle
and then he's calling just American
citizens idiots
we've gotten used to that this is
remember Joe Biden was sold as like the
decent grandfatherly nice guy
could have been further from the truth
and we've gotten used to this from him
but he's just insulted this the
president of the United States insulting
American citizens who are exercising
their free speech rights
and I guess we're supposed to just sort
of uh grow accustomed to that
Donald Trump okay let's get to this uh
Donald Trump was supposed to be
campaigning for republicans in
Pennsylvania
but he took the time during his campaign
speech
um during his rally rather this is a
rally you know we're supposed to we're
supposed to be rallying
uh Republican voters going into the
midterms right
and uh but he took time during this
speech to take a public shot for the
first time at Ron DeSantis if you
haven't heard this let's listen
let's say there it is Trump at 71 Rhonda
sanctimonious at 10 percent
Mike Pence at seven oh Mike's doing
better than I thought
okay so he's going down the uh the
polling data to show that you know he's
in the lead and then he calls Ron
DeSantis Ron to sanctimonious
a few things here
first of all obviously just an
incredibly weak nickname
um he's gonna have to do a lot better
than that
you know if he wants to take down Ron
DeSantis
going in going in grabbing into the bag
for uh just a throwing an insulting
nickname at them
that might have been enough in 2016 to
take down almost all of the Republican
candidates there were there were 19
candidates and almost all of them could
be taken down with just a silly nickname
um but this ain't 2016 anymore and uh
and also Ron DeSantis is a different
kind of candidate if he becomes a
presidential candidate at all and none
of them officially are yet of course
but he's a different kind of Republican
and you're not gonna be able to take him
down with a wake name it especially not
one as weak as that
uh Ron DeSantis is
ineffective conservative governor the
most popular Republican governor
in the country
one of the most effective Republicans
we've seen in my lifetime easily
I say one of I would say probably the
number one most effective when it comes
to
actual policy changes okay getting
policy wins and cultural wins
there has certainly never been a
republican governor in my lifetime as as
um Adept in those areas as Ron DeSantis
and so
you're going to have to try a lot harder
than that
now Trump fans on Twitter they uh
took the cue and they started trying to
build their case against Ron DeSantis
and one thing that you're that's
floating around on Twitter a lot now is
that they're saying that well Rhonda
Santos is an establishment guy
he's an establishment candidate because
of some unsourced Anonymous report about
how the establishment is supposedly
lining up behind Ron DeSantis and
there's these Anonymous sources saying
Paul Ryan and Kevin McCarthy or you know
like scheming to get Ron DeSantis um the
nomination
because apparently Anonymous reports are
trustworthy now
we got Trump supporters who rightly have
spent
six seven years saying you can't trust
Anonymous sources
and the right about that especially
mainstream media Anonymous horses and
now they're passing around as gospel
truth
from the media which is interested in
starting a fight between Ron DeSantis
and Donald Trump and they especially
want to do it before the midterms
and we're just taking that as a as as
the truth I guess
also by the way when it comes to these
establishment guys
Donald Trump endorsed all of those guys
he endorsed Kevin McCarthy this year
he took the establishment and put them
in his white house he gave them jobs
he gave them more power
it's just a simple fact of the matter
there was he did not drain the swamp
didn't even start to didn't even come
close didn't even try
took these people and put them in the
White House
uh
you know handed power over to Jared
Kushner
coven comes along surrenders the whole
country so fauci so
that's what you're going to have to
contend with just just a word of warning
as if we just we do get into the
primaries and we do have the DeSantis
and Trump Showdown
if your if your narrative is going to be
well DeSantis is an establishment guy
we've got four years of trump that
you're going to have to contend with and
we all remember that like we're not
stupid we weren't in a coma
but why are we having this conversation
right now is the question
we're a couple of days before the
midterms we're supposed to be showing a
united front Ron DeSantis is on the
ballot he's gonna win
but he is a he is a candidate
and Donald Trump is at a rally attacking
him
a couple days before the election
what's the strategy there exactly
and you know the next day uh there were
people on on Twitter and on the right
were making a big deal about
the next day Donald Trump he's down in
Florida giving a a rally speech and he
came out in support of DeSantis and he
said yeah you got to vote for DeSantis
and so we're supposed to take that as
well everything's fine you know it's it
was okay
that just makes it worse
that just shows that uh that that Trump
throwing that dig at the Santos that
wasn't part of some 4D chess overarching
kind of brilliant strategy he's just
babbling and so two days before the
election he throws a jab at Ron DeSantis
and then the next day is supporting him
this just typifies two of the biggest
problems
with Trump one is that he just has he
has no discipline
at all
he just says whatever comes to mind
there's there's no strategy to it
doesn't think about timing at all
and also he's not interested in pursuing
a goal Beyond himself like the fact that
fighting as the most prominent
Republican in the country which is which
is Donald Trump
starting a fight with the second most
prominent two days before the election
that's going to hurt conservatives going
to hurt Republicans it's going to help
the Democrats
who are the opponent here
and Trump's Trump's a smart guy he knows
that he doesn't care
just does not care
and and I don't consider that a
a positive at all
and I know you might say well he's a
fighter and just he wants to get in the
ring and fight being an effective
fighter it's like
you get into the and I'm no boxer myself
so my ability to make boxing analogies
is you know my my boxing comparisons are
going to dry up pretty quickly but
what I do know is that when you when you
get into the ring you're not just going
to start flailing your arms around at
random he's a fighter look at him he's
just punching everything
no you're not just flailing your arms
around
it's got to be targeted you gotta it's
all about timing and being targeted and
smart
that's part of being an effective
fighter is understanding timing
it's not enough to just go after someone
the only thing about who you're going
after
and when and why
now
if the scientists and Trump both want to
be president then we're going to get to
DeSantis Trump Showdown it's going to
happen and they're both going to get
bruised in the in the process no no
question about
it doesn't have to happen right now it
doesn't help anyone for it to happen
right now
in fact you could save that
that inevitable period
which is going to be unfortunate in a
lot of ways because again both guys are
going to get bruised in the process it's
just it's it's what it is politics
though it's going to happen no one's
complaining about that but you could
save that
you know you can uh when the the window
of time when that's really happening and
these guys actually are throwing punches
at each other you you could you can you
can condense that window considerably
starting now before anyone has even
announced the campaign is just not a
good sign
and uh and I don't know you know it's
it's too early to make primary
predictions
um the smart money in a primary
assuming that Trump and DeSantis are
both in it the smart money is of course
on Trump
and if I were a betting man that's
probably where I put my money at this
point in the primary
um
and Trump obviously assumes that it'll
be him too but uh I know we all might be
surprised
Ron DeSantis is very popular
and I think his his track record as
Governor is again it's a political
problem for Trump because it was easy
enough in 2016 even going up against uh
19 of these guys it was easy enough to
paint many of not all of them but a lot
of them he could just paint as like it
you know ineffective establishment types
who haven't done anything and they're
just all talk and they haven't done
anything they have no accomplishments
and all that and it was true of a lot of
them
but with the sand this is not gonna be
that easy
because he has real wins you know he's
put he's put points on the scoreboard
and we've all seen that
which also means that we're going to
have more respect for him than we do for
maybe some of these other guys
so you're not gonna have as much leeway
with the voters anyway but we'll see
all right
um moving over to Elon Musk and uh
Twitter
so Elon Musk has put
there's a lot of people talking about
today on on Twitter that Elon Musk has
started Banning left-wing accounts left
and right
and that's because a lot of the blue
check marks on Twitter they wanted to
make a point because they're very upset
about the idea that um they're going to
have to pay eight dollars a month for
their blue check mark and they're not
upset about paying the eight dollars
that's not it they don't care about that
a lot of them have more than enough
money to pay eight dollars what they're
upset about is the idea that anyone can
now pay eight dollars and get the check
mark too so they're they're losing their
their Elite status on Twitter they're
very upset about that and so they were
trying to make some point about the
problem with you know just verifying
anyone so a bunch of left-wing accounts
including Kathy Griffin
they change their their blue check mark
and they change their name to Elon Musk
and then posted a bunch of stuff trying
to embarrass him
and he responded by banning all them so
Kathy Griffin got banned and uh and a
bunch of others too temporarily
suspended anyway
which which is pretty funny
but then he also tweeted this Elon Musk
did
and I wasn't sure about this he says
Twitter needs to become by far the most
accurate source of information about the
world
that's our mission
yeah yeah I don't know about that
see the jury's still out as I've been
saying with um
I think we can assume that Twitter will
be in better hands with Elon Musk than
it was before but that's that's easy
enough to do
um you've got it's it's an easy bar to
get over I'm quite sure that Elon Musk
will get he's already gotten over it so
that is that's cleared
but whether or not Twitter actually
becomes this uh Public Square where free
speech speech Reigns Supreme in a in a
real way well that remains to be seen we
don't know yet
and then I read tweets like this from
Elon Musk and I'm uh I I'm a little
apprehensive
because it seems to me that there are
you can either
try to turn Twitter into the Public
Square where Free Speech Reigns Supreme
or you can try to turn it into the most
accurate source of information about the
world seems like you can do either of
those things but you can't do both at
the same time
it's either a place where you can go and
share your ideas and your opinions and
your perspective with everybody
um
essentially without
limit you know unless you're committing
actual crimes or defaming someone death
threats that sort of thing doxing
someone
so it's pretty easy to see where the
limits ought to be
so it could be that which I think is
what a lot of people are hoping for
or it can be as Elon Musk is saying now
a place where you go for the most
accurate information about the world
and I've never gone to Twitter for that
that's that's not why I'm on Twitter
I I I've never gone to social media for
that
um
but if that becomes the goal then it
seems like well you're gonna have to
crack down on speech considerably
in fact you're gonna have to keep doing
what they've already been doing at
Twitter
which ostensibly is the whole reason
Elon Musk took over
which is to say well you could say every
anything you want as long as it's
accurate
and accurate as judged by our content
moderators so the content moderators
will tell us what is true about the
world and you know they'll they'll set
up the parameters here are the things
that are true and you're allowed to say
any of those things pick from the list
we'll give you a checklist of all the
things that are true about the world and
you could say those all you want to your
heart's content
you can post one of those true things
60 times an hour if you want
hey but that's not actually free speech
is it
no I don't need and I also don't need
this in the reverse
um I wouldn't trust now I would never
trust Twitter's content moderators and I
don't care who's in charge of Twitter
but I would never trust the content
moderators to actually police real
misinformation
a guy would never trust them to do that
but even if I could trust them do I
still wouldn't want them to
someone you know I posted about this and
someone said well no this this would be
good I mean what if they you know trans
propaganda is misinformation and so what
if they start cracking down on that as
misinformation because it is
well that's not actually what I want
I I don't need that
as long as there's no thumb on the scale
let the trans propaganda go to Twitter
and say everything they want we can
easily handle that we can easily expose
it for the misinformation that it is
if you take the thumb off the scale and
if you let us confront this ideology
directly and in plain language and say
all the things that we need to be able
to say if you let us do that then I'm
not I don't need a Content moderator to
police that we can do that easily
in fact in a on a Level Playing Field in
a fair fight I want the trans
propagandists there I want the left-wing
propaganda I want them all there
if it's a fair fight
right because because then that gives us
a chance to expose them to what they are
you try to do this in the reverse and uh
you know moderate them out of existence
then even if you were to succeed well
you've turned Twitter into like a
right-wing Echo chamber essentially and
uh and we're not able to do with it
what what what we should be able to do
which is to use it as a platform to to
engage with these other ideas and expose
them
for the nonsense that they are
so that makes me a little uncomfortable
but we will uh we will see
all right this is from the
post-millennial it says
on Sunday's episode of Meet the Press
host Chuck Todd told his audience to
expect delays in the results from
Tuesday's midterms as many Battleground
States will not have their votes tallied
until well past November 8th Todd said
even though we're all counting down to
Tuesday let's be realistic it's highly
unlikely we will not know or highly
likely we will not know the full results
of the midterms on Election night Todd
then referenced the election of 2020
when many states did not have the
results tallied over
um 80 during the night of the election
mostly because those states were still
counting ballots
from early voting
well that's going to make people very
comfortable isn't it that's going to
allay any concerns by comparing it to
the 2020 election
I know it'll be totally be totally fine
you know just like the 2020 election
it's going to make people feel a lot
better
this is why this is this is supposedly
why anyway uh counting the ballots takes
so long because you have all these early
early ballots that come in
which is yet again the reason why
if you care about election Integrity we
wouldn't be doing any of this
you go to the you go to the the the uh
the polls
on Election Day and you cast your ballot
and that's it
and you know what if you want to extend
the time that the uh that the uh
the ballots are open you want to extend
that time for people to go vote
but I'm fine with that as long as it's
on the day
now as you know personally for me I
think there are far too many people
voting so if it were up to me I would
make I'd make uh the polls would be open
maybe for like an hour
and if you really want to be there you
got to get there within that hour get
there early in line so the people that
that most want to be the the most
motivated
voters will be there I think that's a
better strategy but that's not going to
happen
and if you want to go the other way and
you want to open it for longer that's
fine
as long as they're voting physically on
the day
and you count them on the day
that's the only way to ensure election
Integrity all right one of the things so
this is why it went viral
yesterday SNL had a um
skit about covet and we'll play a little
bit of this but I don't know
maybe a little bit late but let's watch
are you feeling tired and worn down Sick
of the Endless grind at work
exhausted by your family desperate for
some peace and quiet
then ask your doctor about covid but
simply getting covered you're guaranteed
a five and sometimes even 10-day
vacation from all of life's problems I
needed a break just some time away from
everyone so my doctor suggested I get
covid and it was the greatest week of my
life all I wanted was to sit on the good
part of the couch and watch the Netflix
I want to watch and I was finally able
to thanks to covid at first I was
worried about getting coveted but my
doctor assured me it's fine now I'm
triple vaxxed quadruple if you count HPV
so it's my time to shop side effects of
covid include having covet which is
still kind of bad but doesn't it seem
different now I definitely got sick but
I also got paid for 10 days to never
leave a blanket plus I got a great story
I could tell people at work it was like
I had a bad cold for three days
of course I had to isolate from my three
kids because I didn't want to get them
sick but uh what do they eat
10 days to be extra safe
so there's that
you know it's every time I see something
like this it just uh it just frustrates
me because that would have been
that's that's good right there two years
ago
that would have been edgy
and uh and offensive to a lot of people
and hilarious
largely for that reason
but now
it's like they're coming they're coming
around to these jokes and these
observations and everything that most of
us noticed two years ago and we're
supposed to give them credit
and there are far too many people who
are willing to give them that credit
being way too generous I think
uh no it's too too late I mean what was
SNL doing two years ago
like they didn't have a live audience
they didn't I think they should in fact
they shut down completely
I wasn't paying much attention that I I
admit but uh they weren't making jokes
like that I could tell you that
wait until it's completely safe that I
mean that that's comedy these days right
that's what comedy has become wait until
it's it wait until the coast is clear
it's completely safe
you won't offend a single soul and then
make the joke
doesn't work quite the same
let's get to the comment section
[Music]
you know if you're like me you've
probably got a ton of old boxes sitting
around filled with photos film reels and
VHS tapes you may not have looked at
them in years because you no longer have
the projector the VCR to do so worse
they're wasting away in your Dusty Attic
or moldy shed you need to preserve those
recorded moments so they could be safe
forever and you have them forever
trusted by over one million families
families Legacy boxes the simplest and
safest way to digitize all your aging
tapes film reels and photos simply send
everything in and they'll send
everything back on a thumb drive DVD or
Cloud digitally preserving your Memories
Forever each kit includes everything you
need to safely pack and send your
records uh once complete these
Irreplaceable moments can be easily
viewed shared and passed on for future
generations for generations to come last
year I refused to fix my mother's VCR
over Thanksgiving holiday and to make up
for this slide against my dear sweet
mother sweet Grandma Walsh if you will I
got her Legacy box that she doesn't have
to keep her old VCR around and more
importantly I don't have to fix it
because I don't know how to anyway
relive your most important memories this
holiday for a limited time only take
advantage of Early Access to Legacy box
best sale of the Year visit
legacybox.com Walsh to shop Legacy boxes
Black Friday sale that's legacybox.com
Welsh for an irresistible deal
legacybox.com Welsh
Emery says I practically dropped my
phone and looked at my children with
tears in my eyes when Roe was overturned
two then I dropped my knees and thank
God that I was able to live to see the
day when it happened yeah we were making
fun of that NBC show with their their
opening Montage of all these lefties
learning that Roe was was overturned and
they were all distraught and it was very
funny but at the same time it is true
you know it's like there's nothing wrong
if if roe being overturned made you
emotional
um even if it made you tearful nothing
wrong with that we talked about the the
appropriate times for a man to cry all I
think their latest list we're up to
seven I'll make that number eight that's
acceptable
but it should be tears of joy
because
you know this Darkness has finally ended
at least partially
tears of joy over the fact that millions
of babies though not every baby will now
be saved
that's a perfectly fine reason to get
emotional
but getting emotional
over the thought
that your daughter one day will not be
able to get pregnant and have an
abortion is just uh demented
all right
Gerard says hilarious how the AP article
says it is somewhat startling that two
cities that have high African-American
populations uh there's not a single
black player do they think the teams
acquire their players by hosting
city-wide tryouts each year or something
yeah I missed that I I did and I felt
bad that I all the reasons to make fun
of that AP article saying the World
Series was racist because there are no
U.S born black people there were there
are quote unquote people of color as the
as the term is now used
the war in the world series but uh they
were born in other countries so they
don't count is what the AP was saying
but a lot of reasons to make fun of that
and I missed that one I don't know how I
missed it but but yeah they they said
it's even more startling in this case
because the cities are being represented
have a lot of black people and so why
aren't there black people on the teams
well because they don't they don't it's
it's they don't hire exclusively from
the local pool of talent
in fact uh you know it's it's it's kind
of rare on a professional sports team
that you have someone on the team who
actually grew up and lived in that City
uh
Max says what annoys me about saying a
fetus is only a club of cells don't they
realize that we're all made up of a
clump of cells the difference is how
many my heart breaks for these little
Treasures God help us
yeah exactly you could
you know if you want to be a
reductionist in that way you could
describe any human being that way
we're all clumps of we're all you know
we're all comprised of cells that are if
you like clumped together
what does that have to do with anything
and as I have often pointed out you know
we're talking about clumpiness
uh you could go out in public pretty
much anywhere or go to the store and
you'll see lots of people that are a
whole lot clumpier than your average
infant by the way
um John says the wind when does Life
Begin debate is a straw man in their
heart they truly don't care human
sacrifice in their head has been
rationalized and the debate is only a
pretense uh that's true for for many of
the pro-abortion people that's correct
it doesn't actually matter when life
begins this is the premise behind the
kind of shout your abortion movement
it's that um
you're shouting it you're announcing
your abortion you're not explaining it
you're not defending it you're not
rationalizing you're not you're not
making an argument for it okay that's
why it's not hashtag make an argument in
favor of your abortion it's hashtag
shout your abortion uh because you don't
have to explain it and it doesn't matter
if if the baby that was killed was if it
was a baby or a fetus or a lifeless
clump of cells or whatever it was
doesn't matter because you have power
over your body you can do whatever you
want that is
that is uh I think
a morally horrific argument but it is at
least an honest argument that I think
more and more pro-abortion people are
starting to make
um
let's see and finally Cool Runnings says
man Today's Show by Matt has me all over
the place the opening story was
heart-wrenching disagree with the vote
on Election Day only stuff found his
take on Camilla and fetterman hilarious
and back to disagreeing with his take on
Luke Bryan non-apology which he thought
was an apology today was wild kinda why
I like this show never know what turn
will take next from story to story keep
it up daddy Matt
well I appreciate all of that and that
is you know it's like you don't have to
agree with every single thing and um
I do appreciate that and I would like to
just end it there but unfortunately by
by my count Cool Runnings you used
four laughing crying face emojis in this
comment and you should know better than
that at this point so you are sad to say
banned from the show
you know Tuesday is going to be a
bloodbath and I for one could not be
more excited and I'm inviting you to
tune in and watch our special daily wire
election night 2022. election coverage
starts at 3 P.M Central and then
starting at 6 p.m Ben Shapiro Michael
Knowles Andrew Clavin our god king with
a lowercase G Jeremy Boren Candace Owens
and myself will be giving you live
updates as the results come in with help
from our morning wire crew we'll also be
mocking social media meltdowns that will
surely be happening from the likes of
AOC and so many others and there will
also be some very special guests joining
us for commentary too daily wire
election night 2022 will be will be uh
the gift that keeps on giving as we get
into the holiday season and you don't
want to miss a second of it you're if
you're not yet a member go to
dailywire.com Walsh and join us today
now let's get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
today our daily cancellation may be
accused of being a bit unfocused I would
blame it on ADHD but I've already
canceled ADHD multiple times during the
same segment the problem is that I
wanted to dedicate the cancellation to
the worst examples of democrat cringe
heading into election day but the cringe
just kept piling up one on top of
another creating a sort of leaning tower
of cringe a mountain you might even say
a cringe volcano spewing hot liquid
cringe all over the all over the ground
sending particles of cringe into the air
threatening to blot out the Sun and send
us all into an eternal winter so all I
can do is is go through this bit by bit
now I have no overarching eloquent point
to make but then again if you wanted
eloquent points you wouldn't be watching
the show to begin with and so we just
have to Dive Right In with this get out
the vote music video produced by a
leftist pack called Midas Touch you may
recall from Greek mythology that King
Midas turned everything he touched into
gold
it's up to you whether this qualifies
but here it is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
you know it's actually kind of catchy I
mean it's it's not good but like by the
standards of this sort of thing
I don't know it's it's like an early
2000s era of Vanessa Carlton without the
vocal range of the songwriting ability
morphed with Rebecca Black
which which still is slightly better
than what you would expect but still not
great in summary democracy was a mistake
there's a reason to identify as a
Theocratic fascist and when I finally
rise to power and take my rightful
Throne my very first decree will be that
all the get out the vote songs are
banned which I suppose will be somewhat
redundant because voting will also be
banned for the good of the country but
that's not the only form of musical
cringe taking us into election day in
fact somehow
it gets worse in the last week signaling
the
um ultimate form of desperation various
Democrat candidates have started
recording dancing Tick-Tock videos
now this shouldn't be
as all that bad you might think because
for all their faults Democrats tend to
be better dancers than Republicans I
have no data or research to back that up
it just seems intuitively true and yet
it's the worst dancers in the Democrat
Party who are dancing their way into the
midterms here's a very brief compilation
so I'm looking for a yellow bone long
hair star
s I'm a Savage yeah
hacking stupid what was happening
hips come get in my car
Gretchen Whitmer probably fared the best
of that group I would say though she
still looks like your drunk aunt at the
wedding reception unsurprisingly uh when
Beto O'Rourke dances he has the look of
a man holding in a fart perhaps we
should call that dance move the swallow
I don't know then there was Tim Ryan of
Ohio who dances like uh a little bit
like a toddler at a Wiggles concert
and I know I promised that I wouldn't
make any overarching points here but but
if I were to make one I would point out
that the tick tock dances are a symptom
of the total lack of seriousness and
dignity among our political Elite
the countries always had political Elite
Right For Better or Worse usually For
Worse
but at least there used to be a certain
sense of decorum in that class at least
in front of the public
now they all share the same vices of the
political Elite of any other age except
we have to add that they're desperate
undignified you know the desperate
undignified cringe Factor has to be
added to the list now
speaking of which Tim Ryan makes a
second appearance in the cringe Roundup
with a video posted on Friday
um purporting to show off his skills at
the shooting range or lack thereof here
it is
[Music]
thank you
not bad for Democrat
s
not bad for a Democrat he says amazingly
however it actually is bad even for a
Democrat the bar is extremely low when
it comes to Democrats and Firearms after
all these are the people known to
confuse earplugs with rubber bullets yet
Tim Ryan has managed to get under a bar
that would be buried in the earth if it
was if it was set any lower
so let's just take a look at a freeze
frame to assess his form on this so he's
got his knees locked head down
leaning back like he's anticipating
recoil from like a 50 caliber machine
gun
I taught my nine-year-old daughter how
to shoot a BB gun and her form was
immediately better than this
in fact if she had formed this bat she'd
be grounded for a week for bringing
shame to our family and this is to say
nothing of the fact that he's standing
10 feet from the Target and his grouping
still looked like he was shooting blind
and drunk from like 500 yards away
keep in mind too that these are the best
angles and shots they could find for him
they probably had them out there at the
range for like several hours trying to
get 15 seconds worth of usable footage
and this is what they had to run with
that I mean I would have run the footage
right to the trash bin and moved on but
that's just me
it's somewhat confusing as to why they
even put this video out given how
incredibly embarrassing it is for Tim
Ryan but then you realize that they have
no respect for the voters they're
pandering to the assumption is that blue
collar voters in Ohio will be just
impressed that he's shooting a gun and
they'll vote for him on that basis Alone
look he makes the gun go bang bang he's
just like us we should vote for him
that's the calculation they're expecting
which isn't surprising given that these
are the same people who think that you
just learned the word inflation three
months ago
what they don't understand is that gun
rights voters don't need to see you
shooting guns in fact they'd rather not
see you shoot guns if you shoot like
that
what they want to know is that you
respect their constitutional rights
that's what matters to them
but the Common Thread here is that
Democrats do not understand the voters
they're trying to Pander to much less do
they like them or respect them
and that's just another reason why
they're going to lose tomorrow and why
they are today canceled the day ahead of
time
that'll do it for this portion of the
shows and move over to the members block
hope to see you there if not talk to you
tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]